okay ready for this Matt Damon Marion
Cotillard Gwyneth Paltrow Bryan Cranston
Kate Winslet Jude Law Laurence Fishburne
Jennifer ile John Hawkes set is a cast
groundbreaking ceremony for a new
factory did you mention seeing anyone
who was sick and he went on a plane the
airport
No she said she was jet-lagged contagion
is directed by Steven Soderbergh and
it's a film that's about a virus that is
spreading very rapidly and it's just a
kind of film that really realistically
portrays what could happen if a very
dangerous life-threatening virus spread
across the entire population very
quickly it's not a fun film this ain't
some comedy that's in a film you go to
the theater to watch and have a good
time in fact if you go to this date or
sick or if there are people coughing
around you you will immediately like
turn into a little chrysalis and just
hate life all of a sudden because you'll
this movie just makes you feel so
paranoid about germs and and sickness
and disease and the fact that it seems
so realistic and plausible man no no I
go up to your room buddy so we have a
virus with no treatment protocol and no
vaccine at this time you had a seizure
this morning beverage before treats no
no
all the actors in the film do a really
good job of portraying the the feelings
that you might have in a situation and
it's interesting because there's so many
different characters in this movie and
they're all over the world and you'd
think that it would make it really mixed
up because whenever a movie bounces
between different characters a whole
bunch of different characters anyway it
can be really dangerous for the movie
because it can make it seem very jumbled
and mixed up but not here and the reason
is because all the characters are united
by one thing they're all dealing with
the exact same problem unfortunately she
did die right I said can I go talk to
her
mister I'm off your wife is dead what
are you talking about what happened to
her what happened to him this isn't a
movie you go to thinking it's gonna be
so much fun to see this movie about
contagion and mass virus and death yeah
the very realistically portrays what
might happen and I really appreciate
that because it didn't take like a
Hollywood route it had the character
sitting down talking about just really
scientific things this is what could
happen this is what could happen smite
happen all the actors in the film did a
really good job I really appreciate it
in particular Matt Damon's performance
Kate Winslet Laurence Fishburne I know
I'm forgetting someone cuz there's so
many but I really think everyone did a
really nice job on this movie Steven
Soderbergh is one of my favorite
directors it's because all his films
look so beautiful
he's similar to me and that he's really
it seems like he's OCD about the frame
and just sitting in just the right spot
great lighting he always makes his
actors look really good to some of the
issues I had with this movie are
essentially the fact that since it is so
realistic the film gets really wordy at
times in explaining the various
scientific elements of this virus and
this and that and how we're gonna cure
it and everything and so it gets a
little boring at times and it's
necessary to make the film seem
realistic but from a pacing standpoint
at times it does drag a little bit also
all of the film is really good at
weaving all the different stories
together because they're all dealing
with one particular problem because
there were so many different stories and
so many different characters it makes it
hard for the film to have a satisfying
resolution because it's difficult to be
able to end and conclude all of those
different stories in a satisfying way
don't talk to anyone don't
catch anyone stay away from other people
visitors are we're not sure
but for the most part I really did enjoy
contagion simply because it was very
realistically made very well made a
really competent film a really
good-looking film filled with great
performances and it really kind of makes
you feel uneasy about the plausibility
of some of the things they're talking
about so I'm going to give contagion a B
it's figuring up sound faster than we're
figuring it out it's mutating
but if you like this review you can
subscribe to my channel and get stuck